foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
perfect
come on
[Music]
now
oh great
[Music]
[Applause]
KO
ons
[Music]
thank you
fight
s
Perfect
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
tonight
[Music]
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description
you know choto TV
[Music]
is following these steps before you
submit your Clips make sure the quality
of the video is clear put your IGN as a
file name for your video
limit submissions 305 Clips a week per
category
don't spam submissions and don't send
folders with your Clips on avoid
full-length matches or just cut the clip
you want on the desired play Until the
End of the round
next send your Clips via Dropbox in the
correct category
you can always find it on the
description of every ochodo TV series
once you upload your video file if it
prompts you to give your name just put
in your IGN
also these are things you can do if
you're sending a recorded replay match
[Music]
foreign
for some clips to be featured because of
the review process
[Music]